now you don't actually need to do
anything with his skull you just need to
have it and if you've got it if you have
his skull he's like yo who's got my
skull it's it's very blood in the sand
which by the way is a game that I should
absolutely get a copy of and then co-op
with someone because blood in the fan is
part you fitty they got your skull hey
who got my skull
I want my skull back it's like dude it's
not your skull
you had it you you were the fake owner
of it you were the owner of known stolen
property for about 45 seconds it's not
yours
so anyway anyone who's not familiar oh
man I really I really do need to blood
in the sand has a little bit of a cult
following just purely for the absurdity
of it all so it is kind of a fun game as
far as like generic early ps3 cover
shooters go but I feel like it's been
long enough that people have forgotten
and people need to be reminded of the
the beauty that is fitty cent
destabilizing a Middle Eastern nation in
order to retrieve jet war booty a gem
encrusted skull that is not in fact his
like that he has no legitimate claim to
that's the thing like the the setup of
the game is just so amazing it's so
amazing so it starts off with him
playing a concert in in full body armor
he's wearing he's wearing a bulletproof
vest so he's played he plays this
concert or it's the end of the concert
so he finishes this concert and then he
goes into the promoters office and he's
like yo
where's my pay as if that's how you know
international concerts work rabbit-like
where the 50 cent whose whose
performance fee is probably in the like
particularly if this is not a 50 cent
concert like his performance fee is
going to be you know expensive but so he
just walks in like yo where's my money
as though he just performed in a bar and
is looking for looking for his like 500
bucks for the night
but anyway so he goes into the concert
promoters office like where's my money
and the guys like I don't actually have
your money because I got robbed like
five minutes ago and he's like I don't
care if you got robbed where's my money
it's like well look alright I don't I
don't have your money
but here I've got this I've got this
amazingly expensive one-of-a-kind
artifact like ancient ancient Sumerian
artifact that you can have instead and
it's like okay it's ridiculous one that
you wouldn't have enough money to at
least make 50 cent go away and two
people didn't bother stealing the
literally priceless diamond encrusted
artifact historical artifact so anyway
that's the that's the initial setup so
50 cent takes this diamond encrusted
skull this ancient invaluable historical
artifact takes it
and then immediately gets robbed himself
by by some other dude and then he goes
on a rampage
to chase these guys down and get back
diamonds encrusted skull which should
really be pointed out is in fact like
war booty like it has it is a cultural
artifact that is being pillaged in a war
zone yeah
so if anything like that skull should be
turned over to UNESCO for safekeeping
until it can be returned to like the
museum that it belongs in but so yeah so
50 cent spends the rest of the game
chasing down this priceless artifact
that he has no claim to that or he has
only the single like the most tenuous
claim to and in the process of doing
this he just further further
destabilizes an already fragile region
and it ends no this is this is the best
part I don't I I feel like this is a
spoiler but but even knowing that this
is coming in fact knowing that this is
coming makes it even better than when
you actually are watching someone play
the game because so so the the boss the
boss encounter that the game uses over
and over again is so stupid it's just a
helicopter like it's it's a fight
against a helicopter and you use a
rocket launcher and you shoot it down
and now these are different helicopters
every time but the the final boss is
instead of a helicopter it's two
helicopters one after the other but then
you shoot down the last helicopter you
go to where it crashes you grab the
skull off of the the dying bad guy who's
only marginally worse than yourself
really then you and your crew fitty said
and his crew jump in their Hummer take
this diamond-encrusted artifact stick it
on the dashboard shove a cigar in its
mouth kick back and start listening to
our own music as they drive off so so
they drive off 50 cent at his crew drive
off in their Hummer listening to
themselves on the radio the yeah it's
it's amazing it's amazing